En este video vamos a empezar a hablar de
las excepciones a la regla del octeto de la
que hemos hablado en otros videos. La regla del
octeto es la noción de que los átomos tienden a
reaccionar de manera que puedan completar su capa
exterior, es decir, de manera que logren tener
8 electrones de valencia. Ya hemos mencionado
algunas excepciones. Por ejemplo, el hidrógeno,
su capa más externa es la primera, la cual se
completa con sólo 2 electrones; en este caso
se trata de llegar a la regla del dueto, aunque
también hemos visto otras excepciones. El boro y
el aluminio, por ejemplo, pueden formar moléculas
estables donde uno solo tiene 6 electrones de
valencia y no 8. También hay excepciones en la
otra dirección. Del tercer periodo hacia abajo
nos encontramos con átomos que pueden mantener más
de 8 electrones de valencia. En realidad vamos a
ver un caso de éstos con el xenón, así que veamos
algunos ejemplos. Con base en lo que he dicho,
vamos a ver si podemos construir el diagrama de
Lewis para el hidruro de aluminio. El hidruro
de aluminio tiene 1 aluminio y 3 hidrógenos.
Intenta construir su diagrama de Lewis. Muy bien,
hagámoslo juntos. Lo primero que queremos es
contar todos los electrones de valencia. La capa
más externa del aluminio es la tercera, estamos
en el tercer periodo, y tiene 1, 2, 3 electrones
de valencia; después tenemos 3 hidrógenos y cada
hidrógeno tiene 1 electrón de valencia. Si sumamos
todos obtendremos 3 + 3 que nos da 6 electrones
de valencia para el hidruro de aluminio. Ahora, el
siguiente paso es intentar dibujar la estructura
con algunos enlaces covalentes. No queremos que
el hidrógeno sea nuestro átomo central, eso sería
típico, así que pongamos al aluminio en el centro;
después tenemos 3 hidrógenos: 1, 2, 3, y pongamos
sus enlaces covalentes. Ahora, ¿cuántos electrones
de valencia hemos asignado? Tenemos 2 en
este enlace covalente, otros 2 que nos dan
4 y 2 más en el último, en total 6, así que ya
hemos asignado los 6 electrones de valencia,
por lo tanto, ya no tenemos más electrones
de valencia para asignar. Veamos cómo están
los diferentes átomos: los hidrógenos cumplen la
regla del dueto: los 2 electrones en este enlace
están alrededor del hidrógeno y del aluminio, y
entonces la cumplen, desde el punto de vista del
hidrógeno el dueto está completo, lo mismo para
este hidrógeno y para este otro. Sin embargo,
el aluminio tiene 2, 4, 6 electrones de valencia
a su alrededor, no tiene un octeto completo y,
sin embargo, el hidruro de aluminio es algo que
se ha observado. Bien, pensemos en otro ejemplo.
Pensemos en el catión pentafluoruro de xenón, un
ion con carga positiva. Pausa el video e intenta
encontrar su diagrama de Lewis. Bien, vamos a
trabajar juntos. Y, claro, si algo de todo esto
te parece poco familiar, te recomiendo que veas
el video Introducción al dibujo de diagramas de
Lewis. Primero vamos a pensar en los electrones
de valencia: el xenón en realidad es un gas noble,
por lo tanto, tiene un octeto completo en su capa
externa, es decir, tiene 8 electrones de valencia,
y el flúor, como hemos visto en varias ocasiones,
tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 electrones de valencia,
pero tenemos 5 átomos de flúor, entonces tenemos
5 x 7 electrones de valencia, es decir, vamos a
tener que dibujar muchísimos electrones esta vez,
ya que esto nos da un total de 8 + 35, lo cual
es 43 electrones de valencia. Pero tenemos que
tener cuidado, ya que este catión es una molécula
cargada positivamente, tiene una carga de +1 y por
esto tendremos que quitar un electrón. Entonces,
quitemos un electrón de valencia para quedarnos
con un total de 42 electrones de valencia.
El siguiente paso es intentar construir la
estructura con algunos enlaces covalentes simples,
y el xenón será nuestro átomo central, ya que
el flúor es más electronegativo, de hecho, es el
elemento más electronegativo, así que pongamos al
xenón en el centro, y pongamos algunos átomos de
flúor alrededor, 5 de ellos para ser exactos: 1,
2, 3, 4, 5. Ahora, hagamos 5 enlaces covalentes:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Ya con esto podemos ver
que asignamos 10 electrones de valencia,
porque cada enlace covalente tiene 2 electrones:
2, 4, 6, 8, 10, entonces restamos 10 electrones de
valencia y nos quedaremos sólo con 32 electrones
de valencia. Ahora, el siguiente paso es intentar
asignar algunos de los electrones de valencia
restantes a los átomos terminales para completar
su octeto, así que dibujemos estos electrones
en los átomos de flúor. Cada uno de los átomos
de flúor participa en un enlace covalente, por lo
que tiene 2 electrones de valencia a su alrededor,
así que vamos a darles 6 más: a este flúor le
daremos 6 más, a este otro flúor le daremos 6 más,
a este otro le daremos 6 más, al siguiente le
daremos otros 6 electrones de valencia y, por
último, pero no por eso menos importante, a este
flúor le daremos otros 6 electrones de valencia.
Por lo tanto, acabamos de asignar 6 electrones de
valencia a cada uno de estos 5 átomos de flúor,
es decir, acabamos de asignar 30 electrones
de valencia. ¿Con qué nos quedamos? Bueno,
tenemos 2 electrones de valencia que no se han
asignado y el único lugar donde podemos ponerlos
es en el xenón. Como mencionamos, los elementos
que están más abajo en la tabla periódica,
especialmente por debajo del tercer periodo,
pueden desafiar la regla del octeto. En este
caso el xenón ya tiene 10 electrones de valencia
y vamos a asignarle 2 más de esta forma, así
asignamos estos 2 más y con ello hemos asignado
todos nuestros electrones de valencia. Y debemos
asegurarnos de recordar que este es un catión, así
que le pondremos corchetes y un signo positivo de
esta forma. Esto es algo que se ha observado:
se puede tener un átomo central que tenga más
de 8 electrones de valencia, en este caso tenemos
2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12 electrones de valencia. Ahora,
una pregunta interesante es ¿cómo es que
los átomos que están en el tercer periodo
o más abajo pueden tener más de 8 electrones
de valencia? Bueno, es un tema de debate,
pero algunos químicos creen que es posible porque
son capaces de asignar electrones en sus orbitales
de valencia vacíos. Pero, una vez más, esto sigue
siendo una controversia en la comunidad química.